freunde wir sind heute ein tag in meiner
heimatstadt köln unterwegs und ich werde
einen tag lang fremde passanten fragen
was und wo ich essen soll brauche ich
das ganze mache ich habe dabei wirklich
alle bestenlisten empfehlungen von
freunden durch ich war wieder was neues
herausfinden genau das machen wir ich
suche mir jetzt mein erstes opfer los
geht's
wir würden sie gerne nach einer frage
zur restaurants stellen so ein gesicht
ich bin auf der suche nach einer
empfehlung für ein frühstück schwester
aus wo würden sie jetzt wenn sie
frühstücken gehen würden mit einem
freund proben jetzt in diesem moment
weiß ja nicht wie es heißt
haben an diesem vorplatz ja was würden
sie dort bestellen das kommt der bande
und hunger doch die haben eigentlich
alles haben sowohl süße sachen als zum
beispiel mit
schön dekoriert mit allem was dazugehört
strammer max gehe ich glaube dann ist
das genau das was wir wollen ist
doch
was wenn du hast du denn das klarmachen
kirche und das mein herzlichen dank ich
glaube ich weiß genau welchen gemeinste
ist neben dem oscar wo wir heute stehen
jetzt habe ich auch meine maske
gekauften stimmen dass wir das hier
perfekt also wären den ersten laden ist
wirklich eine schwere geburt habe das
freude da freue ich mich jetzt drauf und
hab ich aufgehört mich glücklich in
meinem leben vielleicht zwei mal
gegessen einmal mit word wohnzimmer als
ich für die gekocht haben einmal so also
los geht's
so faßbender wir sind angekommen ich bin
wirklich sehr gespannt ob ich wollte den
laden schon immer mal aus hessen ich
glaube dir nämlich auch richtig gute
backwaren und softguns lust hätte uns
das ein verhindert ist da noch mal
vorbeigekommen zu felde gemacht ich
wollte auch gucken dass sie eben gehen
also sehr sehr gut strammer max landbrot
schwule gekochter schinken zwei spiegel
97 ist auch tatsächlich ein guter preis
oder
zwischen dem karriere nummer eins war
wurde mir der stramme max empfohlen hier
bei ihnen und gerne noch irgendetwas
süßes damit können sie sich überraschen
das ist ganz so gar nicht erst alles
natürlich das coole man kann immer noch
etwas neues entdecken wenn man in so
einer großen stadt ist und man denkt oh
ja ich habe sich dadurch aber ist nicht
so hin folgen das geil ist alles ja
schon oft daran vorbeigegangen und man
wollte eigentlich ja immer sehr leid
ausgegangen es war so interessant aber
es ist heute nicht ins ja nicht social
media also ein echtes kaffee das
hat
hier haben wir also fahren wir die
empfehlung in strammer max hier beim
fassbender in köln auf der mittelstraße
und ich bin gespannt so gut aussieht
sieht sehr rustikal aus sehr ehrlich
aber sowas hätte man auch ein stück weit
erwartet ja also ich bis jetzt nichts
worauf man darauf nicht bock haben
könnte wichtig war jeder speise immer
dieser musik
hier habe ich noch nie gemacht
ein geiler muss ich mir merken schön
warm
richtig herzhaft man also so richtig
mein die jungs das app york also das
geht so super simpel aus noch ein
frühstück bei oma auswendig sondern aber
es hat trotzdem alles ist schön knusprig
natürlich schönen seite bekannt dass du
noch sogar dieser frische kommt
überhaupt gut und da drin gibt es durch
eine riesige auswahl an backwaren kuchen
krieg sonstwas und es ist durch eine
coole empfehlung und bin mir sicher ich
weiß schilling ist ruhig ist entspannt
das wird noch mal auf eine ehrenstraße
ist das frühstück gesorgt jetzt sind wir
in ehrenfeld ein weiterer stadtteil von
köln und hier bin ich auch nicht so oft
unterwegs und kann mir da sicherlich
noch die ein oder andere empfehlung
geben lassen von dingen die ich nicht
kenne egal ob wir einen älteren her
gehabt jetzt suchen wir einfach
sympathische leute die auf uns zukommen
auch insofern
oder kurze frage an alle leute die immer
so straßenumfragen machen so ein traum
und so wie macht ihr das ist antwort
einfach kann alle sind so nett und so
sagt man hätte das für youtube nein
keiner keiner art bot aber wir geben
nicht auf deshalb ist
das okay
wenn du jetzt essen gehen sitzt ja hier
in ehrenfeld oder umgebung wasser zu
empfehlen und lagern laden hermann carl
hermannsburger okay was ist also dein
gott was ist deine bestellung
endlich
ist auch schon wieder voll unger wir
sind für mich sind sie wenn ein heimkind
gelaufen heute nacht kommt richtiges
workout wird aber ich war zu früh
gefreut heute abend hat eiskalt
geschlossen warum es dass es schwer uns
das so unmöglich sowie zwei jungs
gefunden und jungs wenn ihr irgendwo
essen gehen würde jetzt wo würdet ihr
geben wenn jetzt hunger apotheken weil
genau da gehe ich dann hin und ich
bestelle und was ihr bestellen würde
auch gesagt da war ich selber noch nicht
essen die habe ich auch ein bußgeld da
irgendwo in salzburg bild bürger hier
soll gut sein aber selber warschau die
auch später mit dem dahinten wo sonst
das was ständig und einem massengrab
jetzt geschafft
wir kriegen jetzt wenigstens unseren
bürger die beiden jungs haben übrigens
gesagt sie machen bald ein restaurant
auf wer weiß vielleicht sieht man sich
ja auch irgendwann mein aber als bürger
ist unsere adresse und irgendein
scharfenberger fühle ich auch mehr als
und einfachen cheeseburger winzig
ehrlich ist es ja auch gerne scharf
deshalb machen wir uns auf den weg
dorthin
ja machen oder philippsburg ja irgendwas
müssen wir ja sagen oder kunden
wir testen zuerst mal die kommen erst
mal auch gute portion kommt auch schön
am tisch somit so ein tray und so also
bei ihnen ist und ich habe jeden fall
genannt gemacht das merkt man dem rhein
krank ist jetzt kommt es drauf an
welches band dann lasst uns den einmal
probieren ist das wirklich ein riesiger
war gut benimmt nicht verschwinden
hier ist auf jedem feld de la peña ist
ein bisschen so main mainz menschen
burger
hat wenn es nochmal verschafft aber ich
mag das ja nicht eine riesenparty hat
gerade weil dieser sonntag sowieso ehren
wird viel essen und dann wenn man so
nicht so diese war laut hatte schon mal
sehr sehr gut der vor allen dingen
manchmal ist so dass vielleicht zu
einnehmen und auch ehrenbürger ja so ein
cheeseburger bestellt man jetzt
eigentlich auch nicht so im
burger king wie würdest du ihm
vergleichen zu wirken ganz anders ganz
ganz anders ganz anders also dieser käse
der es so schön klebrig sondern so wie
man es mag bei so einem kieswerk aber
noch hat er auf jeden fall recht so auch
aus precious an sich mag also ich finde
es wirklich ein grund wird dieser
paragraph ein grund für die bekommen 100
prozent abdecken also und solide ist so
ein burger nachdem man sich nicht tot
fühlt also nicht so ein geistiger wo du
gar nichts mehr kannst das ist jetzt hat
mich meine augen geöffnet und ist für
mich ab sofort der krasse bürger der
welt aber es muss ja auch gar nicht sein
und jetzt freue ich mich auf fünf
kilometer laufen für das abendessen
so wie sehr es am neumarkt auf der suche
nach einer empfehlung fürs abendessen
und wetter ist wirklich komplett scheiße
ihr könnt jetzt auf jeden fall nicht
mehr diesen zwei stunden rumlaufen film
machen deshalb hoffe ich dass wir
schnell einen tipp bekommen und
habe auch schon wieder was zu essen
wie heißt diese waren nämlich genau den
pop retten irgendwie
sonderlich hilfreich ist in der
ehrenstraße das eigentlich wollt könnt
ihr dort empfehlen weil die bestellen
haben sie
sich gefreut hat ihr seid die zweiten
gewertet abendessen anstellen könnt euch
nicht vorstellen wie wird das gerade ist
und wir haben lange gesucht heute morgen
und heute mittag aber probleme hatte ich
einfach mehr von channel das habe ich
auch selten generell gegessen aber die
gehen jetzt mal ab ok können uns ein
paar wolken und schicken klingt auch
wieder scharf ich wieder bock drauf und
dieses recht
[Musik]
wurde die bank ein und schicken bauer
empfohlen die wirklich einmal neben für
hier bitte frische reifen zu fahren
[Musik]
sondern eine schaukel damit sitzen jetzt
hier na ja man ist einfach ist das ich
bin gespannt auf das essen eine wolke
chicken 0 klingt schon mal sehr sehr
weht eine frische avocado drauf wir
haben
es ist mit einer scharfen soße
erdnusssoße auch ich freue mich sehr
darauf ist nur wieder eine riesenportion
aber
wir sind beide seit dem wir gemeinsam
videos drehen ungefähr zehn kilo
schwerer gemacht dann früher bei den
persönlichen computers haben die
wenigsten noch den ganzen tag ist
wackelt weil ich so kamera gemacht er
ist einfach nur noch hat man danke eric
nicht okay hier ist noch kein checken
raum haben wir noch nicht soviel heißt
ich habe schon sehr gut für mich jetzt
nicht bestimmt für viele kann ganz gut
für angenehme präsenten ote fand ich wie
viel davon ein bisschen show ist dass du
gesund ist weil die soße ist bestimmen
sollte schon sehr wenig und so ne aber
erst auf jeden fall messen das kannst du
dir trotzdem guten gewissens fans so was
reichen frische sachen 33 auch
irgendwann zu erwarten dass wir wenn wir
nach empfehlungen gehen gutes bob
bekommen so ne ich bin mit der auswahl
sehr zufrieden und ich mache ist
grundsolide im weiteren zuschauer ist
würde ich sagen aber ich mich umso mehr
ok und sowohl keine chicken ist jetzt
leer wir haben uns die geteilt und
wirklich mal würden die daten also das
ist richtig viel was bleibt ist ein
feuriger geschmack im mund und
dankbarkeit weil diese tollen empfehlung
heute sein wir können das wieder an der
stelle auch beenden das war wirklich
cool ich liebe diese videos am ende von
so einem tag mit dem man voll happy dass
ich mich somit schafft und dass ich so
neue sachen kennengelernt habe weil das
einfach geil wenn man muss wirklich
sagen macht es wirklich nicht weiter
anzusprechen
erfolgreich
wieder machen